[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka coach carter and what
if i told you that for the next nine
weeks we're gonna be breaking down the
new marvel mcu show what if you'd
probably be gutted but you're stuck with
me and in this video we're going to be
going over all the easter eggs things
you missed and also giving our theories
on the episode itself it massively
connects to captain america the first
avenger and the entry asks the question
what if peggy carter was the one who
took the super soldier serum instead of
steve peggy carter for me is one of the
best characters in the mcu and she's so
good that you would travel back in time
and kill her husband just so you could
be with her now peggy is someone who's
just as strong willed as steve and in
the first avenger you might have noticed
that before he died from the grenade
that she too rushed over to it as well
she's just as worthy as he is to carry
the shield and if rumors are to be
believed then captain carter will be
popping up at some point in doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness the
showrunner of what-if has also confirmed
that she will return and that her
character will connect each multiversal
season of the show therefore her origin
story is something that we need to get
up to speed on and the episode begins
with the watcher voiced by jeffrey
wright explaining the multiverse though
not explicitly stated i do like how you
can come to this show just viewing it as
an offshoot of the stories that you
already know or you can see it as a
consequence of the branched realities
that have been created since sylvie
killed he who remains the watches are a
race of observers that look over time
space and reality and the last time we
saw them in the mcu was during guardians
of the galaxy vol 2 when one of their
agents aka stanley told about all the
different personas he'd played in the
franchise the voiceover sounds very much
in the same vein as the opening of star
trek namely the captain's log which
described the voyage that the starship
enterprise would be going on through
space here the voyage is slightly
different and we explore the multiverse
and all of its trappings in this
introduction we can catch characters
like t'challa carol danvers tony stark
thor black widow and lastly steve rogers
the prism of reality then breaks and we
can see the eye of the hulk peggy carter
loki anya's guardians going before the
un thor steve rogers t'challa is
star-lord his mother raimonde doctor
strange cap shield nick fury red skull
tony stark and proxima midnight next
there's killmonger with an arc reactor
in his chest hammering away like tony
did in the first iron man movie doctor
strange again t'chaka loki peggy again
nick fury vision obadiah stain and when
the layer first cracks you can also
catch zombie tony the captain caught a
shot is picked and we then fly past the
hulk t'challa is star-lord black widow
the hydra stomper the collector loki
hawkeye captain marvel and a couple more
characters that fly by at light speed
next we stop to see space inside of a
silhouette of the watcher and you might
also notice that there are several
coloured stars which look like they
represent the infinity stones in
infinity war we line up these elemental
crystals were hurtled across the
universe with the formation of the big
bang and these lights being dot amongst
the cosmos could be hinting towards that
we then go to the hydra occupation of
europe and see as several soldiers with
the logo emblazoned on their uniform
march in unison this intro feels very
similar to news reports that were used
in the 40s including the footage of
germany spreading across the continent
which was parodied in things like the
opening of dad's army who do you think
you are kidding mr red skull and we see
his face moving through flames which
seems like it's pulling from the opening
of terminator 2 when we watch as the
skeletal face of the robot moves through
the fire the watcher tells of how the
story happened originally and we see an
animated version of steve's super
soldier procedure in the first avenger
we also cut to his shield on the ice
which we see revealed in the opening
scene of that film things happen a
little differently for peggy and though
she is transported to the future too a
lot of moments divert and sort of go off
on their own path now we cut to an
alternate universe and we see that steve
is still going forward for the procedure
even though dr erskine asks peggy if
she'd be more comfortable in the booth
clearly he sees the good in her too and
steve also gives her a smile meaning
that he knows she's worthy it's here
that we're also introduced to colonel
flynn who pretty much takes over the
role of tommy lee jones's chester
phillips we actually see phillips get
shot in the scene and this happens
instead of erskine who originally took
the bullet this kind does die in the
scene but clearly they couldn't get
tommy lee jones back so just took him
out as quick as possible now flynn is
voiced by bradley whitford who you might
know as being the father from get out
and also for his role in the handmaid's
tale he's pretty much someone who views
war as a man's game and he sees peggy as
being someone who's lucky to be in the
room which is something that he says
throughout the episode however her being
in the room is what changes everything
and the observers remaining in the lab
has a massive knock-on effect in the
first avenger they went up to the
observation booth and this is where the
hydra spy left his cigarette case which
he used as an explosive to kill several
of the commanders and officers that were
at the procedure here they remain on the
ground floor and thus it's possible for
the spy to blow up a lot of the
equipment and also to run directly to
the sea room and take it he shoots steve
but peggy kills him whereas originally
the spy managed to make it out and steve
had to chase after him the moment in
which he fires the trigger also looks
very similar shot in the first avenger
when she managed to hit the driver of
the spy's car whilst they were fleeing
the power on the machine begins to drop
and thus they have to carry out the
procedure immediately or everything will
be lost flynn suggests steve first but
he can't go in because he's been shot
and then he suggests howard who refuses
because he says he's just a buttons guy
thus peggy puts herself forward and it
sets off a chain of events that leads to
her becoming the first avenger she puts
the super soldier serum into the machine
and it's nice that they use the same
angle and imagery as they did in the
original movie the trailer for what if
hid this moment and pulled a bit of a
bait and switch on us and made it seem
like peggy was the original choice and
they completely removed the fire and
destruction from it they also changed up
the moment in which howard lowers his
glasses which looked massively different
in the original first look this moment
clearly pulled from the first avenger in
which he lowered his glasses in the
exact same way and a as they say it's
like poetry it rhymes they don't really
say it just just mainly me and george
lucas now speaking of symmetrical shots
the way peggy sits back into the machine
and the framing of this scene is also
identical to how it appears in the first
adventure this attention to detail is
carried across to how the serum is
drained which lines up exactly to how it
was in the movie also peggy and steve's
reaction upon getting injected happens
pretty much the exact same way as both
the eyes shoot open they also use the
same camera position when he comes out
looking like i do after a two hour gym
sesh and when she comes out looking like
abby from the last of us part two god
damn now flynn goes off on one and he
says that he was promised an army but
instead all that he got was a girl this
is actually pulling from the first
avenger as in that philip says he was
promised an army but all he got was a
chorus girl this was of course because
cap at that point was performing the
star spangled man with a plan which is
still a banger we can confirm 78 years
later and it's still a banger now nurses
take blood from peggy similar to what
happens to steve post procedure and flim
beretta he mentions the ssr aka the
strategic scientific reserve which is
what shield was called before it became
the organization in 1946 cut to peggy
smashing the punching pack like you
should smash that like button because
damn this is a good breakdown and also
yeah whilst you're here if you're not
subscribed then make sure you do because
we're covering the show for the next
nine weeks shabow now this scene of the
punching bag which he hits so hard that
it comes off the chain is of course
referencing steve doing it in the
avengers after he had to adjust to life
in modern day we see that steve is on
his way to recovery and she chucks white
plates like their frisbees foreshadowing
how good she'll be with the shield steve
says it could be worse and that she
could be on a uso tour which he was of
course put on during his first solo film
and yes it is still a banger we can
confirm that now now steve watches
soldiers marching outside and he says
that bucky just deployed with the 107th
this is actually another nod to the
first avenger as bucky was in that
regiment and steve himself initially
applied to it as well as he said that it
was his father's unit unfortunately he
was rejected
and though peggy apologizes to steve he
says not to worry and that he never was
much of a dancer peggy says that maybe
he hasn't found the right partner and
shout outs to skinny steve for still
bagging the girl i seen a tweet the
other day on twitter i can't find it so
don't ask but they said that peggy only
likes steve because of the super soldier
serum but i'm glad that this series
showed us that you can still be a loser
and pull a hottie god damn
now we cut to townsburg which is where
the first avenger opened tonesburg is
actually a pivotal location in the mcu
and it was where odin fought the frost
giants at the beginning of thor in thor
ragnarok it was the location where odin
died and he said remember this place
home this came to be and in avengers end
game we saw that the displaced as
guardians had ended up there and made it
their home red skull pulls in and the
shot of his car driving up is exactly
the same as how it appears in the first
avenger with a strong focus on the squid
that hydra worships if you've seen
agents of shield then you'll know that
this was a big focus in the show and the
organization pulled together to make a
literal manifestation of the god called
hive here we see it in full effect and
the beast at the end looks a lot like
schumer gorath who too is rumored to be
appearing in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness stark and ko are
able to monitor their movements here
because of the gamma signature coming
off the clock tower and bruce banner was
brought in on the avengers to track the
tesseract due to his knowledge of this
radiation see it's all kind of connected
it's all connected
do that thing i always do now this scene
is very similar to war room one from the
first avenger and even down to the
lighting maps and miniature flags
they've managed to recapture the scene
perfectly the moment with red skull is
very similar too and he remarks on the
tesseract being the jewel from odin's
treasure room which of course comes from
the film unlike that movie though the
soldiers gunned down the tower keeper
immediately whereas they let him survive
for a bit longer in the original film so
that red skull could could just
monologue for a bit just talk about
nothing for a bit more now the tower
keeper was played by david bradley who
you might know from game of thrones and
harry potter however here the voice
actor is different it's from this point
onwards that things really start to
split apart i'm glad that they took the
show in a brand new direction as up
until this point a lot of the episode
had just basically been the steve rogers
story with a peggy carter's skin on we
then jumped to the bar scene in which
stock presents her with a shielding
costume and in the original movie the
people satya were steven bucky as peggy
hadn't rescued him at this point whereas
steve had the order is different and
steve originally stormed the camp with
just his prop shield whereas peggy
instantly has the vibranium one
this allows her to immediately go out
and catch zola as well as the tesseract
peggy jumps down with her union jack
uniform and shield and don't it make you
bloody proud to be british bring it
bring a tear to your righteous cavanaugh
she takes down a giant aryan soldier
which i might be reaching but is someone
that could be based on steve rogers to
show that she's stronger hey look they
don't call me reach richards for nothing
but aryans and the idea of the aryan
superman was something that was lays
throughout hitler's ideology he believed
that blonde hair and blue had people
descended from the gods themselves and
he wanted to create a master race of
them thus peggy taking down this symbol
early on has a lot of metaphorical
meaning behind it that makes her first
mission a really important one for a
number of reasons now peggy getting zola
and the tesseract massively alters the
course of the way that things happen
because he's not part of red skull's
organization he can't experiment on
bucky and also can't make the tesseract
based weapons on the other side of this
having the tesseract early means that
howard can create a suit of armor named
the hydra stomper which allows steve to
basically be this story's iron man peggy
says steve owes her a dance and she then
heads into europe and steals a motorbike
which massively echoes when steve rodon
won in the first avenger kind of feel
this scene references the great escape
namely when steve mcqueen's character
hilt attempted to jump the fence on a
motorbike at the end of the movie rather
than getting caught though peggy smashes
through it and she rescues several
characters including dum dum duggan and
the guy from the original movie union
jack there's also jim morita played by
kenneth choi kenneth actually ended up
playing the high school principal in
spider-man homecoming and in his office
we could also catch a photo of jim bucky
hasn't been experimented on so he's in
the cell too and he says who you're
supposed to be the queen of england
that's and it's impressions like that
which is why i don't use clips from the
show itself now it makes me right angry
this does just shut up for a second
right angry as mean superhero nexus were
talking about this and he reminded me
that our dear old queen she didn't
become that until 1953 so they just they
didn't research this bit and it just
makes me so angry i'm raging now we
could do a shot which is very similar
the one from the first avenger that
happens around the hour 19 mark this
includes peggy busting through a door
with the rest of the howling commandos
and steve of course did this in a solo
movie it was also referenced in falcon
in the winter soldier episode 4 when
john walker and battle star burst into
the flag smasher hideout again it's like
poetry sort of sort of looks the same
now several tanks show up and steve
arrives in his new dancing shoes to take
them down iron man's first mission was
against tanks and we can see that he too
has a heads-up display inside the helmet
similar how tony's appears in the movie
now we then see a montage which uses the
same music from the first avenger and we
see flynn taking credit for peggy
busting up heads steve writes hello from
brooklyn on the arms of the hydra
stomper and i think this is an opposite
to the bombs in the first avenger which
all had locations written on them
together steve and peggy fly across the
skies fighting as part of the raf and we
get an awesome one-take shot in which he
takes down planes single-handedly while
steve flies her from one to the next cut
of the red skull's hideout which is
vastly different to how it was in the
first avenger as skull planned to bomb
europe with a plane he of course needed
one with a runway but here he's trying a
different tactic hence why he doesn't
have that location this is a castle and
though i'm not sure exactly which one
that it is the germans fortified several
of them including places like kolditz
which they turn into a base now we do
learn that it's called the crates and
that it's located in the black forest
but i searched for this and couldn't
find anything on the map or at the
location in the film where eagles dare
we saw as a team of soldiers infiltrated
hohenwef and castle which i've
definitely pronounced strong however
where eagle stare does get a nod in this
episode as it's the name of what the
train operation is called similar the
first avenger several nazi troops arrive
to question what the red skull is up to
and he ends up killing them however as
he doesn't have the tesseract he doesn't
have a tesseract gun to shoot them with
and he instead fires at them with a
german pistol which is called a mauser
at this point he unmasks and we see
steve and peggy in a bar together where
she brings up that she can't get drunk
which we know is shed in steve's mcu
counterpart peggy talks about how the
serum has changed how people view her
and that it's helped her to be heard
steve says that he's still a skinny kid
from brooklyn and nothing without the
suit this is of course an easter egg
that calls back to his line in the
avengers in which he told tony that he
was nothing without it peggy says the
suit is nothing without the man inside
and she calls him a hero and he says the
same back unfortunately before they can
kiss howard cockblock shows up and they
head out on the train mission which of
course pulls directly from the first
avenger this includes a zipline moment
and peggy pulls bucky up to which he
says thanks you almost ripped my arm off
bucky of course ended up having his arm
ripped off and he became the winter
soldier due to the events that happened
in the scene originally the train is
revealed to be a trap and steve is
apparently killed in the explosion but
we learned that the hydra stomper
protected him and that he was captured
much in the same way that bucky was
peggy goes to zola but unlike the way
that phillips approached him which was
with a stake peggy doesn't make that
mistake hey and she gets the invite of
him the hard way the ambush castle
decreates and peggy beats the crap out
of everyone the team ends up splitting
up with howard and peggy going up in one
direction whilst the howling commandos
go in another red skull places the
tesseract inside the device which does
look slightly similar to the housing
unit that it was held in during the
first avenger and everything comes to a
head this opens support love and much
like how the the the tesseract sort of
spelled doom for the red skull in the
first avenger the squid comes forth and
kills him i know he survived but yeah
the guy didn't have a good time now the
commandos come across the hydra stomper
which we see is held in a circular
contraption this looks very similar
setup that tony had with his original
iron man suit and the basis of the
entire thing looks a lot like leonardo's
vitruvian man steve jumps in the suit
and it's powered up which allows him to
fly to fight the squid too peggy grabs
the sword and goes head to head with
that in her shield which pulls on the
iconography of artheria knights the
hydra itself was of course an ancient
beast that called from myths and legends
and it makes the finale feel very epic
howard tries to power down the machine
and he mentions spending a week with
hedy lamarr who was a german singer and
actress hedy was actually used as the
inspiration for madame mask a villain in
the show agent carter that peggy had to
take down also if you haven't seen agent
carter then definitely check it out as
it's highly underrated but well worth a
watch it's also on disney plus which you
brought you probably watched this
episode on this morning so
go back there quit this videos crap just
just go back and watch that now the
castle starts to collapse as the beast
grows bigger and steve saves the howling
commandos unfortunately his suit runs
out of power and peggy pushes the squid
back into the portal steve says you owe
me a dance lesson and she makes a date
for saturday night which of course calls
back to the final conversation between
the pair in the first avenger the portal
then explodes and steve and howard are
left wondering what happened as we see
the tesseract being the only thing that
remains it is of course capable of
opening doorways through time and space
and we could at the project pegasus
research base from the opening of the
avengers instead of loki being pulled
through the portal peggy is and she
arrives to see nick fury and hawkeye the
former tells her the war ended 70 years
ago similar to how nick told steve at
the end of the first avenger and peggy
looks devastated even though she says of
course we won the war she of course gave
up everything trying to achieve victory
i think that as the seasons go on we
will see her very much taking on the
role of steve she still owes him a dance
and have no doubt that she will find a
way back to him once they get around to
the end game and phase three events of
what if now as for my thoughts on the
episode i thought this was a really good
first entry that perfectly set up how
what if it's gonna work they managed to
recapture several moments from the
movies and i made it a really good watch
just even just picking it apart trying
to pinpoint all the different easter
eggs beyond that though i think the
animation works really well and again
it's a highly produced show that
succeeds due to getting most of the
voice cast back as well as the score
returning once more this makes it feel
authentic and if the season continues
with this level of production i think
it's going to be a must watch even if
you're someone who doesn't really tend
to check out animated shows i really
really really enjoyed this episode i was
lucky enough to see episode 2 early
which is also something i think you guys
are going to absolutely love i don't
want to spoil what the concept is in
case you want to go in with some
surprises but it's very well put
together and has a lot of cool
characters showing up in it overall i
really enjoyed this one and i hope that
we see captain carter sooner rather than
later now if you enjoyed the video then
make sure you leave your thoughts below
on the show and what you think could be
happening with the character in the
future also we are running a competition
right now and giving away 3 mc box sets
on the 30th of august all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we picked the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so
that's you message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our latest marvel breakdown on screen
now which will be popping up in one of
the end cards don't know which one yet
but just click it just remove the mouse
about do some random clicking and i'm
sure you'll get to it if not then thank
you for saying through the video i tell
you what mate you have a you have a
bloody great day you i'll see you next
week take care peace